go wild and crazy like Afghani
irrigation ditches or Geographic
sinkhole locations you know don't
suggest area 51
what was that water based cremation that
is the kind of high-grade suggestion
that we are looking for water-based
cremation I'll be honest I've no idea
what it is but water-based cremate which
seems like a contradiction in terms and
itself doesn't it thing is I'm gonna
need five suggestions and that's the
first one you have set the highest bar
imaginable I'm gonna take foot right
okay I feel like we should divide the
room up so everyone kind of get some
thinking time and it will gets a fair
show so kind of in this area here what
you want to hear a rap about any of you
an orangutan crosswalk great amazing
really you heard her Ewell I'm gonna be
even more nonsensical what are two
things that have never seen each other
and likely never will
orangutans a crosswalk water-base
cremation kind of middle front of the
room that's this kind of semicircle here
what you want to hear about that no no
no that that feels like it you know
that's too obvious well for a British
person boy stirs both our food and an
animal and obvious no camouflage paint
yeah and they are we all remember our
first day working in a garage or a
mechanic and there will ia going NASA
the Gophers and camouflage plane and a
long wait now is a that's what I used to
work in a gas station that's okay I know
with this face and hands what so
camouflage paint water-based cremation
orangutan cross worked back at the room
what's it gonna be strip her panties
yeah that's what we like and this kind
of corner of the room or unwrap that
climaxing dolphin
you really feel I feel like people are
just going like you said no animals if
we smash animal to an adverb then we're
fine so uh some of your like is that an
adverb I'm really not sure so is it an
adjective it's how adjectives or adverbs
who knows so climaxing dolphins
water-based cremation stripper panties
camouflage paint an orangutan crosswalk
those are amazing suggestions thank you
for those now what's going to happen is
I'm going to turn those into a
completely improvised completely made up
on the spot
freestyle rap that is a wrap there's no
being written will never be seen again
and has never been performed before and
do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly
toe-curling ly bad as you're expecting a
middle-class white British boy to be
thank you for that laughter of
conviction they're just like oh no I'm
definitely sure this is going to be good
thank you sir okay let's do this let's
drop that beat and have some fun start
decorating walls you say I can't but I
get a nice hand of the camouflage paint
I paint the color I say it goes up here
I don't like the beige or the Magnolia a
lot of walls mix kind of greenish and
brown and if you're in the woods you
better hunker down in a ghillie suit
guys what the hunters wear if they want
a surreptitiously pick off a bear from
far away but I do it in my dining room
people walking in they strobe I don't
zoom
say I never thought this was possible I
went to the hardware shop at the store
the guy provided me with the can of the
colors I called up all my friends I gave
them a howl of my brother came round
yeah he went oh and their user little
paintbrush not a big roller we had a
nice chat we had a nice talk
we played the Beatles album when they're
on the crosswalk Abbey Road but have you
ever even thought about million years
ago before they wouldn't have evolved
properly to be a hairy man old creature
of the jungle orangutan not based in
London much more father coming from an
area called Sumatra near Indonesia major
Carter the orangutan is trying to crash
into your car there they just stand
still they look like a chimp but they're
different chimp a black fur with the pig
face a rabbit's hand look mouth like a
coconut they've got their lips going
crowd yelling pucker up and this is one
thing my balls broke bigger if I saw an
orangutan asked as a stripper get in on
the pole spinning around I'd say a hope
orangutan lets his panties down I wanna
see ya
I really prefer if the curtains the
great master ginger fur Oh sexy yeah
I've got
large range I like the primates with the
fur or rage and stripper panties oh this
did amaze me they're so flimsy because
they're entirely lazy they last about
two shifts on the pole you've gotta make
sure you give up money and they go to
the store buying you this sold in bulk
if you break your panties you might
throw some salt and say are my best
panties have gone like golf I got a hole
in one I'll work it for you this is what
we do and when I perish I will admit to
you that well it's strange it's kind of
frustrating that you have to go in fire
for all that cremating I've been waiting
really I know I wanna mix it up and mix
with the h2o turn into a powder turned
into dust
kind of like an ash with the faint smell
of must poured into a picture of water
in front of my grieving sons and
daughters and say this what do you want
in the precipitation River sister water
cycle all of this probation means that
he will live to ever got no mustaches
but still you can put the water scared
those ashes having fun last thing I do
the first world was dolphin then we went
through a whole sense of foreplay open
that chasm the finger in the hole then
the dolphin orgasms they go click click
it sounds like a drum track
do you ever seen a little flipper do a
climax he does a backflip like Free
Willy
if you touch on his Free Willy I'm very
sorry that I later in town if I see your
child with the syndrome downs swimming
with the dolphin I'll stay in the pool
please stay away from that Dolphins
genitals they're so famous for getting
aroused and if they do that then Beach
is on the crab
what a delightfully unsavory note to end
easy-fit not this then lovely people to
close out the night a real treat for you
I know you're excited about this even if
your faces aren't showing it it's gonna
be a little thing called a freestyle rap
that has a rap made up on the spot it's
based in town these sessions there is no
trickery to this it's not prepared it's
not rehearsed it will never be seen
again and don't worry it's not going
anywhere near as bad as you're expecting
it to be in let's drop that beam let's
have some fun steal a loaf of bread then
you follow me Nik five pounds and it's
off to the colonies in the 800 other
things were plundered they sent all the
guys down under wanted nickel offer
bread from a market store sorry you get
thrown in a horrid dark cell or you can
be set on a deathly both people were
like I've got no choice here I vote to
go to the land heat 52 Celsius and also
the kangaroo what about the indigenous
people the 12 there we were British we
really didn't even [ __ ] care
doesn't matter it's a stain on a legacy
and if you go down to Adelaide you can
see that everybody there's descended
from convicts even though they say
they're a free colony that's [ __ ]
because everybody there is a criminal
nobody understands this is true y'all
I'm told they're two years in the last
five Jesus Christ I'm lucky that I made
it out alive
I'm over there and I must warn I serve
it hard when I'm on the courts in mell
born
having lots of fun like Lleyton Hewitt
scoring all the points yeah show you how
you do it well I will a backhand it
always lands you do the overhead smash I
don't understand I like to get the slice
I get the topspin I can hit a ball boy
in his speech in he gets knocked on his
butt it comes from above he gets 0
points and in tennis that's love
backhand amazing my favorite here
that's a tennis one year I'm
appreciating rip what you think the
shape of the earth is Chris I'm glad you
asked mister rhombus I think it's
totally flat is that true you know yeah
[ __ ] anybody that says is a globe I'll
laugh in your face brother that's
hysterical you think that the planet
spins spherical now is just the shape of
a chessboard and let me make sure we're
all assured that we won't get alien
hordes coming down from space and trying
to blast us away with their phases in
our face
Trump's car wax yes of course he puts
federal funding building up a space
force like Reagan Tip is light a Star
Wars program the ship will open doors
will get Elon Musk and instruct him to
lead us to alien destruction but every
corner of the planet safe you see
because it's shaped like a square with
the vertices that's the edge is
diagonal I wrote to go we did the prison
colony and I must say so remind me what
the other one was the bear in my
thinking me of my Oh buzz okay this is
amazing I like retro acids a buck teeth
while I wear thick creamy glasses my
name's Michael Myers doing the accent
Michael Caine also when it doing some
acting but Mike Myers he played fat
bastard - it was the Scottish guy an
easy accent to do dig in my belly
that's what he used to say really really
20 years ago probably today has anybody
thought of it recently there was Verne
Troyer he played mini-me Austin Powers
was dr. evil with a little finger on a
date in the past a girl I would bring
her and say we koala why the time and
ours she says is your sense of humor
Austin Powers the air I like the bit my
taste is a mountain I like the bit where
he sipped water and pissed in the
fountain to pretend the he was the angel
on topic with any more things that we
need to do the topper were there any
other ones but good to be ten today
[Applause]
[Music]